This homework is about a card game called Foxes and Hens.
There happens to be another game called Foxes and Hens
which is a checkers-like game, but this one is different.
This one is a card game, so there should be a deck of cards.
We're going to simulate those on the computer.
Here's the scenario that the game is trying to talk about.
We have a yard into which some free range chickens can roam.
I'm going to give up on my drawing skills and go to a schematic.
So a chicken walks into the yard,
some time later another chicken walks into the yard,
and at some point a fox may come.
And when the fox arrives, it eats all the chickens and everything is gone.
So this deck of cards, each card has either a fox or a chicken on it.
We flip the cards over 1 at a time to see who arrives next.
We're playing this game as a 1-person solitaire version.
The way the game works is we're going to take the whole deck of cards,
flip them all over, and before we flip each card,
the player has a choice.
The player says, "Should I gather up the chickens that are in the yard?"
That will be 1 possible action.
And if I gather them up, then here there's 2 chickens. I would get 2 points.
But the card that gets turned over, whether it be a fox or a chicken,
that animal would get scared by my gathering action and would run away
and be lost forever.
The other action I can take is wait.
So I just watch the chickens in the yard, wait for the next one to arrive,
and if it's a chicken, then I'm in luck and there's 1 more in the yard.
Once they're in the yard, I spread out enough chicken feed that they won't leave,
so they'll always be there.
I can wait for more chickens to accumulate within the yard,
and then when I gather them I'll get a higher score.
But if I wait too long and a fox arrives by flipping over the card and getting a fox,
then I lose all the chickens.
And so my choice then is before each card is unveiled, either gather or wait.
Then we see what card is unveiled. We get a new state.
Now, if you're familiar with playing blackjack in Vegas,
you'll know that if you try to count your cards, you get in big trouble and you get kicked out.
But here, counting cards is legal.
At the start of the game, you know exactly how many cards there are,
how many of each kind there are--foxes and hens--
but of course they are randomly shuffled, so you don't know
which one is going to come up next.
The state of the game then is defined by a score--
the number of chickens I've gathered so far--
the number of chickens currently in the yard, and the complete collection of cards
that haven't been dealt yet.
So we're assuming you have perfect memory for counting cards
and you know exactly how many cards of each kind are left,
but of course you don't know which one is going to come up next.
This is a partnership, so I've written some and I'm going to call on you to write some.
Here's the top level function. We call it foxesandhens.
It takes a single player strategy, and it takes the number of cards of each type in the deck.
Here we have a 52-card deck, of which there are 7 foxes.
It creates that deck as a string of F and Hs.
And the initial state then is the cards is a string of 52 characters,
the score is 0, and the number of chickens in the yard is 0.
And then we just go through the whole deck.
We're going to be popping off a card from the deck each time,
and we ask the strategy function for an action,
and then we're going to define--and I'm going to ask you to define--
this do function, which does an action to a state and returns the new state,
and that's going to be the score, the yard, and the cards.
And we keep going until the cards have gotten down to 0.
So every time you do a do action,
there's going to be 1 less card in the state that gets returned.
And at the end you get the score.
I don't think I mentioned this rule yet, but at the very end
you automatically get together all of the chickens that are left in the yard
if there are any remaining.
So your score should be the score you've accumulated so far
plus whatever is in the yard.
I want you to write this do function.
Remember that there are only 2 actions: gather and wait.
So do has to apply those.
It has to pick a random card out of the cards,
figure out what to do with that according to the action,
and then return the new score and yard and the set of cards without that card--
the set of cards with that card removed.
And the cards have to be represented as a string rather than as a Python set.
I've given you a sample strategy for playing the game.
I call this strategy take5. I wrote this function.
There's no truth to the rumor that Paul Desmond and Dave Brubeck wrote it.
The way it works is it waits until there are 5 hens in the yard,
and then it gathers them up.
Here's a function for computing the average score of a strategy
over N number of games where N defaults to 1000.
And what I'm asking you to do is to write your strategy function here, a strategy function here,
that takes a state and does whatever you want here.
I've added just return something, but you should alter your code to do the right thing.
And we want you to make sure that your strategy is superior.
What does superior mean?
It means that your strategy's average score compared to the average score of take5
must be 1.5 points better on average.
So keep working on your strategy until you can come up with one that's superior.
If you want, you can try to figure out how to define the optimal strategy,
but you don't need to do that as long as you beat take5 by 1.5 points.